Und leute ich weiß montags 12.30 ist vielleicht nicht die beste zeit zum streben
Es gibt ja leute die müssen arbeiten habe ich gehört um die uhrzeit
so soll vereinzelt
vorkommen
Ja leute ich weiß auch nicht so genau also es ist sehr merkwürdig
Aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich bock weiter paar runden battlefield zu spielen
Ich wollte eigentlich vorhin ein video aufnehmen
So mal allgemein so ihr wisst ja das letzte video zu battlefield 2042 und sowas ja
Wo ich mich mal drüber auslasse ob sich denn jetzt wirklich auch für die hardcore battlefield fans die es noch nicht gekauft haben sich vielleicht lohnt
Mal rein zu gucken ich denke übrigens dass ich das immer noch nicht lohnt
Es lohnt sich nur wenn man das vielleicht mal im sale kriegt und wirklich gar nichts anderes findet was
Was einen irgendwie happy macht so als battlefield
Veteranen dann kann man sich mal gedanken drüber machen aber es ist deutlich näher an einem fertigen game mittlerweile dran als vorher aber zumindest
Ich wollte vorhin ein video aufnehmen und ich habe auch schon angefangen ein paar sätze dazu aufzuschreiben
Aber ich dachte so ich könnte ja eigentlich auch noch ein paar runden spielen im stream beziehungsweise ich habe mir gedacht ich könnte paar runden
noch spielen
Und wenn ich paar runden spiele kann ich auch streamern machen
Jemand da spricht irgendwie für das game weil man sich mal so überlegt
Also spricht auf jeden fall für das game wenn man sagt auch nach zweimal paar stunden man hat noch bock
auch mal einzuschalten und paar runden zu spielen
Aber nur rush ihr kennt mich rush only ich kann mir conquest und gerade gerade breakthrough kann ich mir in dem spiel nicht geben
Ich habe übrigens jetzt auch rausbekommen
warum
Ich so abgefuckt war mit assault rifles zu spielen
Die sind verpackt die sind nicht wie man in den patchnotes lesen kann einfach nur
Genervt worden was so den recoil und den den bullet spread angeht nein der reset vom bullet spread
Wenn du taps schießt ja dann sollte sich eigentlich deinen bullet spread
reduzieren aber der reset nicht richtig
Deswegen habe ich auch gestern so oft einfach random durch leute durchgeschossen obwohl ich genau drauf gewesen bin ich bin gestern halb durchgedreht bei
Und das ist verpackt also mal wieder was neues am start wo da ist sich wo man sich so fragen muss ob da ist ihren graben
überhaupt ausprobiert im vorfeld
Ja anscheinend sind assault rifles nicht nur krass genervt sondern auch noch verpackt ist natürlich tolle kombination
Und ich habe übrigens nachgeschaut
Legacy ihr passt doch das ist doch legacy feature field und container mit legacy features mit containern
Vergessen was ich sagen wollte achso ja ich habe nachgeschaut
Es soll tatsächlich mit season 5 also mit der aktuellen season eine überarbeitung von hourglass kommen
hourglass ist ja die letzte also die eine der miesesten maps überhaupt und eines der und die letzte map die überarbeitet wird
Allerdings
nicht direkt zum release von season 5 sondern soll im laufe im laufe von season 5
soll die überarbeitung von hourglass kommen das heißt dann hat man ernsthaft
Ihr müsst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen die nächste season kommt ja irgendwie wieder september oktober oder so was da muss man sich mal
überlegen dann haben die zwei jahre nach release gebraucht die eh schon nicht vielen maps in diesem spiel
so zu überarbeiten
dass sie
annehmbar spielbar sind ich würde noch nicht mal so weit gehen und sagen die sind sondern nicht gut spielbar
weil machen wir mal kurz battlefield 2042 mal kurz eine kleine
map tierlist
ok also
Kann man das vielleicht auch auf englisch stellen die seite dass ich irgendwie die map
einfach nur jen
Shit man warum ist es warum hat es kein sprach warum hat es kein sprach slider
Wo kann ich die langweilig umstellen
Ja
Also was haben wir was haben wir für maps machen wir mal kurz zurück so kleine
map tierlist flashpoint
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern
Was war flashpoint?
Die im gebirge die die die mit den dem ja von von der von der season davor
Ist schon schlimm wenn du noch nicht mal ein anderes map namens weißt welche maps eigentlich ist
Ja das ist die mit dem gebirge die so ein bisschen an in rush so ein bisschen an die
Mit der zweiten base so ein bisschen an demament peak erinnert
So vom vom gebirge her und der und dem map layout ja okay flashpoint
Die ist okay
Spearhead die ist in rush auch ganz okay stranded
Die ist auch ganz okay also die neuen maps sind tatsächlich in ordnung exposure exposure muss ich tatsächlich sagen finde ich
recht pepega in rush
Ich habe es nicht oft gespielt mit den neuen mit dem neuen mcom placement vielleicht ist es jetzt besser
Aber die letzte version fand ich nicht sonderlich
gut spielbar in rush hourglass die schlechteste map ever
Also wenn es wenn es so was wie z tier geben würde dann käme hourglass da rein
hourglass ist übrigens auch diese famous map wo damals
shroud war das glaube ich
Wo schraub battlefield gespielt hat nach release und dann mit dem jet in so in so ein hochhaus geflogen ist und abgeprallt ist und
Nicht nicht zerstört wurde
Der clip erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer dran der clip hat er ein bisschen die runde gemacht
Also hourglass ist wirklich z tier schlechter geht es nicht und ich lehne mich mal aus dem fenster ich sag sogar in allen spielmodi
Conquest weiß ich nicht genau ich spiele sehr wenig conquest das wisst ihr breakthrough für n arsch und rush auch für n arsch
hourglass sucked
so discarded
Nicht ganz so schlimm wie hourglass
Und auch mit der überarbeitung ich muss ehrlich sagen ich mag die map nicht finde hourglass
discarded
ist auch
müll
Manifest finde ich fast mit die beste map die im release des games drin war
Finde die spielt sich ganz gut
das neue mcom placement in rush gefällt mir aber nicht weil
Ich finde es war erst gar nicht mal nötig da so viel dran zu ändern
Die erste map in die ersten mcoms in den containern waren ppga ja aber das war aber rush hatte auf manifest einen schönen verlauf
Von der küste auf den berg hoch und jetzt ist es sehr inspiriert einfach erste base kisten zweite base kisten dritte base kisten
Okay, dritte base ist glaube ich tankstelle aber
Trotzdem manifest manifest ist ganz in ordnung
kaleidoskop
rots map in rush
orbital
anfangen müll danach
okay
Und die raketenbasis beziehungsweise hier diese was ist das raketen ist ja das ja die diese die diese base hier das ja mal die rakete
Diesen rush auch ein bisschen doof aber das geht noch das ist so mittleres tier so z tier oder so würde ich sagen break away
Eigentlich auch müll
renewal geht so
Mal gute runden mal schlechte runden geht so okay bleiben wir bleiben wir mal dabei eigentlich die hälfte der maps
schrott
Okay sind wir mal fair ein drittel der maps immer noch schrott
Ein weiteres drittel der maps spielbar und ein weiteres drittel der maps ganz okay
So so ungefähr würde ich sagen wie gesagt auf rush bezogen es ist natürlich meine meinung
Letztendlich hat jeder so ein eigenes ein bisschen einen geschmack was maps angeht ich glaube ich glaube wir können uns alle darauf einigen
Dass our class einfach schrott ist in jedem spielmodus und ich frage mich ernsthaft ob die überarbeitung von our class
Was bringt weil es hat sicherlich seinen sinn dass die überarbeitung von our class bis jetzt aufgeschoben wurde die wissen einfach nicht was sie mit
Der map machen sollen was was willst du mit dieser schrott map eigentlich noch wie was willst du damit machen
Ich wüsste nicht wie man die recyceln kann außer einfach noch mehr kisten an alle stellen stellen was sie machen werden
Bisher sahen ja map überarbeitung so aus einfach überall kisten hinstellen
Montag ist immer frei montags richtig ja deswegen bin ich jetzt ja auch on wie gesagt die zeit ist äußerst unglücklich
Was man auch sieht es sind gerade 85 ganze 85 leute im stream
Ist halt auch eine blöde ist schön dass ihr übrigens alle da seid die da sind
Ist natürlich eine blöde zeit die meisten leute müssen jetzt arbeiten
Und wohingegen irgendwelche it bustle streams man seinem chef vielleicht noch als weiterbildung verkaufen könnte wird es bei einem battlefield
2042 stream natürlich ein bisschen gerät man vielleicht ein bisschen in erklärungsnot
So ich werfe das game mal an übrigens wenn ihr euch fragt
Arbeiten richtig cringe
Wer macht denn sowas
Also wirklich cringe wenn er arbeiten muss
Ihr macht das game mal an mal gucken übrigens für alle die sich fragen
Weil ich sag das jetzt weil es die letzten zwei streams öfters mal aufgekommen ist
Für alle die sich fragen lohnt es sich jetzt rein zu gucken also
Einfach antwort ist wenn ihr das game schon habt auf jeden fall es gab eine neue season es gab auch ganz viele sachen die ich
cool finde wobei cool in
Anführungsstrichen halt mit ihren
Möglichkeiten die sie haben
Jetzt bleibt immer noch ein battlefield light aber ein paar ganz coole sachen dabei
Auch die attachments für world weapons und sowas eigentlich ganz gut also wenn ihr geld schon für das game ausgegeben habt dann auf jeden
Fall denn aktuell sind die spieler zahlen halt auch ganz gut
Weil das ist klar also aktuell sind die spieler zahlen auch ganz ganz brauchbar
ein an sich ist halt
Immer noch ein witz aber es ist schon ganz okay
Aktuell also wenn ihr schon geld dafür ausgegeben habt dann macht das wenn ihr euch fragt
Oder denkt alter ich hätte mal richtig bock wieder auf eine runde battlefield und
Lohnt sich zu kaufen dann würde ich sagen es lohnt sich zum normalen preis nicht zu kaufen
Aber ihr könnt mal drüber nachdenken wenn das irgendwie reduziert ist so für 20 euro oder so kann man sich das mal geben
Okay, wir machen mal
Warum wollen die mir eigentlich allen ernst madden nfl 24 ist nfl
Das ist doch football oder ist nfl ich dachte immer nfl ist eishockey nee aber das ist football
Was ist an die nhl ist ist eishockey alle die amis mit ihren liegen das blickt doch kein mensch durch
Und davon abgesehen interessiert mich auch absolut gar nicht so null
Ich meine mich interessiert quasi eh schon keine sportart so wirklich dass ich die verfolgen würde
Also klassische sportart die ein oder anderen e-sport tournaments gucke ich tatsächlich wobei es die letzten letzten
Letzten 1 2 jahre tatsächlich sehr sehr wenig geworden ist was ich e-sport gucke also overwatch ist ja eh komplett für mich gestorben war ja
eh schon nicht weil ich schon nicht nicht schaubar eine ganze weile
Es gab eine zeit da habe ich sehr viel cs geguckt mache ich auch kaum noch
Das letzte größere e-sport turnier was ich geguckt habe war glaube ich
das letzte
Wie heißt das international dota 2 wo ich einige games geguckt habe
Und das muss ich sagen als jemand der dota nicht spielt ich finde die veranstaltung einfach gut gemacht
Was was bei dem was bei dem diesjährigen
Dota turnier wohl irgendwie die leute ein bisschen verwirrt hatte weiß nicht ob ihr das ob ihr das mitbekommen habt
Sie hatten irgendwie so eine porno darstellerin als moderatorin oder als als reporterin oder als
Spieler interviewerin oder sowas ist irgend so eine webcam porno darstellerin rumgerannt
Das habe ich auch aus dem nachhinein irgendwo gelesen okay, naja warum nicht ja
Aber das turnier das turnier ist wirklich super organisiert gewesen kann es nicht sagen also man merkt schon
Dass das auf einem anderen level ist wie so ein crap wie overwatch league oder sowas
Ja ich weiß nicht warum was sie sich dabei gedacht haben aber anscheinend haben sie das für einen guten move gehalten warum auch nicht ja
Buber
Okay auf geht's vielleicht soll ich mal die musik ausmachen mal schauen ob windows
Wie sieht eigentlich mein battle pass aus bin ich jetzt eigentlich 23 nee was fehlt mir noch free
Moment auf was bezieht sich denn das free hier unten
Leute das UI ist so ppg ich weiß überhaupt nicht was die wollen von mir
Ach das kriege ich nur mit dem premium battle pass ach so nö nö könnt ihr mal einfach knicken
Von mir kriegt ihr kein geld mehr ich habe mir den jahrespass gekauft allein schon für den
Für den für den vertrauensvorschuss sollte dem ja eigentlich bis zu meiner rente premium in dem game geben aber nee
Ich warte ja noch auf level
Also ich hoffe ich habe genug motivation akuma skip missions er braucht so was
Ich hoffe ich hoffe ja noch dass ich die g36 sorry sorry nicht die g36
Waffen namen rechte kaufen ist ja outdated ich meine natürlich die
kek w 46
Aber es ist eindeutig die g36
Ist das nicht in warzone 2 oder generell in den letzten call of duty teilen auch so exposure nicht auch so gewesen
Dass sie die waffen namen so ganz merkwürdig gemacht haben so so wie hieß wie hieß die mp5 jetzt in
Ausschnitt wir sind der hat geholfen wir sind attacker wir sind attacker
Was anderes kommt mal das ding da hätte ich mal wieder bock drauf ist es ist es wie
lachmann hieß das ding doch oder in
nicht kein sein wenn es darauf lachmann
Ist das ding doch in mb2
Oben ist irgendwie habe ich gedacht dass engage nach
Ja lachmann
Das ist auch so ein ding ich teilweise erkenne ich diese dinger gar nicht richtig die die eigenen teammate marker
Weil die weil die oftmals so in den hintergrund geraten
Warte mal wir sind wir sind der nee ich wollte gerade sagen das ticket anzeige ist komisch an der stelle
Wie was werde ich hier einfach geschneidt
Anzeige
Okay, leute erste runde
Präpariert mal für ppg am
Wie ei moment wir spielen
Wir spielen gegen ei
Wir haben gegen wichs gegen wen haben wir gerade gekillt wie wichsos weifu
Die leute haben wieder namen heute waren
Was ein dämlicher namen
Pass auf den den den facen wir jetzt und bashen den
Da ist er wieder wichsos weifu
Gebascht haben wir nicht ganz sicher wo die hinsind
Oh shit verähmt ich sagte richtig richtig massive ppg geähmt
So geht es mir die ersten paar runden immer und den restlichen stream auch aber die ersten paar runden ist immer schlimm
Oh Mist ich dachte wir haben es schon fast
Okay, oh shit
Dachte ich komme vielleicht noch irgendwie durch aber da sind teammates da können wir uns spawnen
Spawne ich gehe lieber bei dem rein
Wie viel tickets haben wir noch 60 okay hier das sieht ganz brauchbar aus
Shit das wird schwierig hier rüber zu kommen hier pass mal auf yolo
Okay nice
Da ist schon einer auf dem dach
Da ist er schon wieder ach nee wichsos warflos ich habe irgendwie aus irgendwelchen gründen weifu gelesen
Da ist er wie schnell spawnt der kerl eigentlich kann mir das mal einer erklären
Okay
jetzt aber lege henne
Pass auf da kommen gleich noch mehr
Ich kämpfe ich kämpfe mir jetzt hier einen ab
pass mal auf
Ja ja ja ja
jetzt
jetzt aber
Die haben jetzt ernsthaft noch diffuse kit
Alter was war denn das
Was sagst du dazu starfield ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was starfield genau war
Okay, wenn du jetzt sagst ein game dann ja ja das ist mir auch klar
Aber fällt mir jetzt gar nicht ein welches
Okay unten ist richtig was los leute smoke
Okay schlechte schlechte smoke posi
Okay, der wird geschotten
Packmann immer in battlefield der den du nicht siehst man immer den du nicht siehst
Shit da sind schon wieder welche
Okay, ich sollte ich sollte schnell respawn weil ich glaube nicht dass ich dass ich den rats krieg das neue betreffende pg. Ach das
Ja ja das hat mich nicht so geschockt
Okay, jetzt sollten wir es haben
Ich glaube wir haben es
Jawohl
Können die mal sterben? Nö, haben keinen bock
Haben sie gesagt. No pass, gestorben wird hier nicht. Auf dem dach ist einer
Ist das seriously in dem moment wo ich aufs dach hoch bin aufs dach vom dach runter gesprungen ja sehe ich das richtig
Bräuchte man so eine smoke granate um das auszumachen. Ist das noch gefährlich jetzt?
Bin mir unschlüssig wo die letzte base ist. Ah das ist die base die unten im tal ist
Da konnte man doch von oben runterjumpen
Das probieren wir mal aus. Das habe ich das habe ich lange nicht mehr gespielt. Rush letzte base hier exposure mal gucken
ne
Hier ging es schon mal nicht runter
Der mal mein pick of wish bestellt
Ich kann sehr... ach ne das ist schon alles unten oder?
Ne finde ich gar nicht das ist das ist eines der der eigenständigsten map die dieses spiel hat
Game hallo
Player in parachute ja das hätte ich auch sagen wollen
Alter wie das wackelt
Okay, wir müssen auf jeden fall hier lang nicht da unten
Der rest sagt hier müssen wir lang. Jawohl hier ist gut
Mal kurz heilen
Da sitzt er in der ecke dachte ich würde gerne nachladen
Die legehenne ist am start
B okay niemand auf B
Bin mir nicht sicher ist nach ist nach der runde ist hier vorbei jetzt
Bäm
Zwar nicht wirklich objektiv aber zumindest
Ordentlich was gekillt die runde
Most wie der hat mehr kills aber das hätte ich noch mal ein zwei mehr gekillt
Nix so jetzt gucken wir mal kurz auf die uhr ach es gibt ja keine sekunden mehr in der windows uhr ich habe vergessen
Das ist so schlecht ich wollte eigentlich jetzt ja
Es gibt halt keine sekunden mehr in der uhr
Okay, 13.04 ich wollte gucken wie lange als 13 ziemlich genau 13.04 war das
Ich wollte gucken wie lange es dauert bis die nächste runde wirklich startet also gefühlt dauert das viel viel viel zu lang
Ja ich weiß es gibt zig uhren online aber warum gibt es keine sekunden anzeige mehr in der windows uhr
Das ist das ist auch legacy features
das letzte windows 11 feature
beste map ever
Da habe ich darauf gewartet dass ich jetzt hourglass spielen darf
Das ging erstaunlich schnell moment es geht noch nicht los es geht noch nicht los
Sie sind noch nicht gespont ich mag sekunden wenn ich wissen will wie viel zeit vergangen ist ja
Da sind also wenn man wissen will wie viel zeit vergangen ist genau dann sind sekunden schon sehr praktisch
Okay jetzt geht's los
Eineinhalb minuten und das ging schnell das matchmaking war instant diesmal
Eineinhalb minuten eigentlich zwei weil ich habe erst nach dem outro geguckt eigentlich zwei minuten
Zwei minuten zwischen den runden von also bevor man die kontrolle weg hat über die player
Die kontrolle weg hat über die player über die über die spielfigur. Oh Mist was habe ich hier ordentliche attachments dran machen man
Wir spielen die beste map im spiel leute
Beste map im game
Gibt keine bessere ich hoffe die ich hoffe die wird nicht überarbeitet weil du kannst perfektion nicht überarbeiten
Richtige banger map ja
Mal gucken wir vielleicht gucken sie jetzt richtung a und nicht so sehr ob ich hier flank action mache über b
Okay wir sind wir sind wohl schon dran
Soll ich meine ich soll mir mal
Da mal jetzt mal gut hier lasst mich doch mal in ruhe
Okay muss ja doch rüber vielleicht
Der spread reset mit tap mit burst nicht das verbuggt
Okay wenn wir glück haben
Einfach fünf gegner vor mir da machst du nix die sind wirklich genau gleichzeitig aufgeploppt schnell
respawn
Respawn timer ist übrigens auch outdated overrated sie betet das braucht man anscheinend nicht
Damage also das ist so fehl mit den assault rifles hast du nicht mal gescheit schießen kannst
Ihr habt es gesehen die hälfte der börse ist einfach komplett durchgeflogen
Er ist
Keine ahnung wo er ist
Ich kämpfe jetzt unter der treppe
Oh blöd richtig blöd in die einheit zu gehen in dem moment
14 was ist mit dem los
14 kill ja krasser schneider dude
Charlie mike seid ihr auch charlie mike
charlie mike leute
Ich auch aber ich habe eine klimaanlage an da muss man nicht derzeit
Best ich hoffe die wer die map wird nie angepasst ist einfach so geil hier so übers offene feld ist einfach das geilste
Zum glück treffen die nix
Die deckung ist